- [Voiceover] Gilbert Faku is a farmer.
His homeland is remote,
near the bottom of Africa.
His life, his wealth is in his farm
and the herd of cattle he tends.
But what he found in his backyard
has brought him on an
extraordinary adventure.
(light pop music)
(speaking foreign language)
During the centuries
of European navigation
toward the Indian Ocean,
ships frequently passed
Gilbert's homeland on South
Africa's Eastern Cape.
One such trip ran aground,
leaving countless spoils.
And Gilbert is one of the
few who knows their location.
(speaking foreign language)
His finds are varied, usually
bits of porcelain and beads.
But his most prized possession
is what keeps him coming back.
(speaking foreign language.
It's a jewel-encrusted
pendant so valuable,
yet he refuses to sell it,
well, for money, that is.
(speaking foreign language)
(upbeat light pop music)